they've got everything you need for your
linen closet at Boleyn branch start over
yeah London this is tough for me because
I come from a long line sheep selling
middlemen okay like what I'm here I love
hearing about this wonderful company and
how they've got these great sheets but
keep in mind there are middlemen out
there who are trying to jack up the
prices on your sheets well there's my
new work oh my god this attitude I feel
like it's pervasive in America now we
used to be a country of middle people
not just men we've got two middles
across the partition from us Andrew
Collins here my Christine is here I had
one I don't have time to meet everybody
guys
[Music]
Thomas Lennon is here you know him
from Reno 911 now the author of the
young adult book ronan boil and the
bridge riddle we can say hit hits we can
say here children I know right who does
that you I know what is going on missile
you are so prolific take a day off guy
you know of a serious teachers on TV
land every Tuesday at 10:00 p.m. this
guy is everywhere
Thomas Lennon one of the funniest people
that exist it's nice to see I know it
was weird last time I saw you we were
together on like one of those game shows
that you have to sit out for like nine
hours straight and it seems like it's
gonna be fun
and you're like enough throw a ton of
money at you and like this is gonna be
great
and like hey meet Kareem abdul-jabbar
and the Kareem abdul-jabbar doesn't say
to you all day is really weird we
talked he was mad at me okay it was just
like the around
listen that taping hasn't aired yet
right a little bit like trying and
Vivica Fox yes that's right that's right
and you and me the classic foursome and
then before we shoot the game show the
set caught on fire oh yes so like
nothing happened for like five hours and
then there was a weird thing going on in
my trailer that you came I came to fix
your trailer yeah I was just kind of how
porno movie start it was so nice of you
I just remember being in my trailer
there's this like piercing like beeping
going yeah I was just meditating like I
guess I'm just gonna talk it was a
carbon monoxide warning and the great
thing is I came in and I turned off the
thing that was warning you assuming you
would just fall down dead at some point
it was either I either saved your life
or quietly killed you you do a lot of
those shows though right like we I've
done a lot of those game shows enough
enough that you look at the rut I didn't
know who was gonna be there until I got
there and I was hoping for like a good
god that's like a god I thought I
was gonna pal around with Kareem
abdul-jabbar like what if he and I like
get a Vespa with a sidecar and like
we're gonna have some times me and Kirk
came in I'm like mmm
I just helped him with his marker a lot
and he was so serious when it came to
playing the game it's called to tell the
truth yeah it's three people telling
what two of them are lying but they all
say that like I'm an alligator Wrangler
and you have to guess which then you
have some questions you're all lies we
were both bad we kept losing it's a hard
game but it was fun to hang out with you
for like nine hours oh it was so cold
somewhere well you were also basically
nude that was on you that was on my
stylist you know sometimes you just they
don't really know what the vibe of the
show is you're wearing this you were
wearing jeans and like a tiny bit of
duct tape I just sometimes I just you
know you go into styling session it's
show business exactly sometimes just go
in and win just well you know what
happens all the time with me with these
stylists as I go in for these fittings
tell me about it I know what on like
I'll put on a bra and they're like
that's right that's the look oh my god
bra I'm dead duct tape and then I
convinced myself that's all I need to
wear as a bra because in the fitting
twizzlers bra blue sprinkles mist crazy
era mist but I was so excited to be with
you on that show because I had worked
with you before on @midnight you were an
executive producer at midnight what a
much heated on that show I think
you beat me a couple times I think I did
but you were also nice to lose that show
a lot at that show well you weren't I
was there a lot you were there yeah
which if that counts is good I don't
know just participating I participate
one the participation you were there a
lot that was such a fun show at midnight
and and that was the first time that I
had worked alongside you
having been a fan of yours for so many
years so it just like blew my mind that
I got to even in meet you I of course
know you from your character lieutenant
dangle from the Reno 9-1-1 series and
movie under weirdly that's an underrated
movie it's so funny I went and saw it in
theaters Crestwood mall boy I thought
that was a movie was gonna do better
yeah yeah tell me about that you know
how every time you're like always
stylists are always like just wear a bra
yeah my life is I thought that movie was
gonna do better yeah I mean so what does
it feel like because you've had your
hands in a lot of movies and you've
written a lot of you got some hits and
some Fox also and there's a dog walker
so I was three weeks post yeah I know
how you feel yeah what movies have you
written biggest flop biggest hit would
be like knighted Museum what's been
great amazing biggest flop would
probably be taxi with Queen Latifah and
Jimmy Fallon fire with Vin Diesel I mean
holy loaded hell baby did you guys know
that Thomas Lennon wrote these movies
yeah the tattooed on my back just crack
what does that feel like when you feel
like a movie is gonna be yeah what
something flops well no the way when I'm
alone was interesting because it opened
like I think today would be like it made
ten million dollars or something like
yeah and I was like you know it costs
ten dollars so so that's yeah I was like
a moderate ended up making money on like
video and stuff like that but we got
called like you got a call Monday from
the head of the studio and I remember we
got a call from the hood
a studio at Fox seems like boy I really
thought this was gonna yeah that's -
that's okay I mean we're friends now and
everything but ya know it sucks it's
like they kind of like it's like a minor
breakup yeah when do you get the numbers
in its released on Friday generally they
can tell them they can track a movie
here's what's weird they can track a
movie the Wednesday before it comes out
kind of because like for real flops that
we've had like taxi
we got a call the producer called us to
say he was leaving town like Thursday
night before it was even coming out he's
like hey we're all gonna be radioactive
for a little while yeah and then he like
left the country on his jet but what
song is taxi a bad movie or people just
didn't really see all the above it was
both a bad movie that no one saw so it's
not your fault
no but what you but the thing is that
most people don't know is that you write
a script and then it's no longer yours
unless you're a producer on well unless
you're doing like art house movies that
you pay for yes big studio movies
they're gonna they're gonna chime it was
there was that a rude awakening for you
as a screenwriter when your first movie
kind of got out of your hands and you're
like what is happening now
what was weird here the first movie we
wrote was called um let's go to prison
based on a book called you were going to
prison that Bob Odenkirk directed and we
actually saw cut of it that we really
loved and then the studio took the movie
away from Bob and they're like it was
doing okay and they're like let's make
it really upbeat and cheerful so there's
a whole new ending and the first time I
saw the movie with its new everything
was in the movie theater and I'd brought
like 20 people to see it and I was like
this thing sucks I'm sorry and then we
all went to book it a bit bow like I
says when you have a real real disaster
go to book it up oh that's good you're
gonna feel better and get the lemon
chicken try to sit in the Pope room you
know it takes it takes a sting off of
epic failure what is the most obnoxious
thing about this business about the
movie yeah about just the business in
general like is there's one thing you
could change about it like is there
something that you take it personally
at times oh sure if as soon as you can
get over taking everything personally
Ben and I actually wrote so if a book
out now there's not my first book but
the first book I ever wrote was called
writing movies for fun and profit that's
right and fun and is crossed out so it's
actually called writing movies for
profit we say is like once you can get
over how bad your feelings are gonna be
hurt like most of the time yeah you can
you'll get through it
but you gotta get ready to be like yeah
pretty yeah it's gonna yeah it's gonna
sting yes not for everybody but it gets
easier once you have faced rejection and
this is a big conversation I had with
one of my best friends Ken Marino I said
you got to be really careful as an actor
and as a comedian and that because
you're used to so much disappointment
that at a certain point you've gotten so
good at being numb to it that you also
don't experience any happy parts of the
good part
yeah you gotta be really careful about
that cuz you'll get so good at just
being like mmm I didn't care anyway
that's a really good point you gotta be
careful I read something I write I
bought one of those books you know
that's on the racks at Hudson News where
it's just like generic titles like is it
like how you're gonna do something for
me books right like it was called mental
toughness it was just a bunch of
different articles about it one that I
read that really resonated with me and
is that athletes that are like the elite
athletes when they suffer so they have
the Olympics to look forward to every
four years right and in between that is
all these World Championships and if
they in World Championships mean a lot
to them now if they lose at a World
Championship and they let that defeat
really get to them then they aren't
gonna be ready to start training for the
Olympics which is still on their plate
coming up in a couple years anyway so
they've learned to not to take a hit and
to be like if that hurt that sucks but
not to wallow in it because otherwise
you'll lose out on training but also
they talk a lot about about about how
they celebrate their wins they really go
hard and like it because I think to your
point we don't let in the happiness yeah
yeah you can't get like so good at being
numb stuff that you don't know how do
you celebrate what are you gonna
celebrate the release of this book Ronin
Boyle bridge and the bridge of riddles
it's a hit right now it's number one in
children's Europe books by the way I'm
crushing the who was Princess Diana book
I'm just saying that's the number to
[Music]
explaining Princess Diana to children
and I will crush it with my mind wow do
you are you so good in so many things
how did you write when when did you get
into children's literature when did you
go I'm gonna take a stab at that you've
written movies for for the same kind of
right this is it's more sort of like a
young adult actually like yeah a funny
adult could read it too yeah so it's
it's really for like like high school
kids who are finding or grown-ups who
like funny stuff so it's not great and
the answer is I'm right compulsively so
I'm always doing something you write
compulsively do you wake up every
morning and write or what's your all
right yeah and is it therapeutic for you
do you feel like if you don't you what
is that if I don't do it I'll be sad
really
it always been that way for you very
long long time as soon as I got in the
state and I realized you had to write to
like be in the show and survive it
started to become like a little bit of a
compulsion
yeah well it's worked out I mean this is
we're gonna actually have our resident
lisper read andrew has a lisp and we're
gonna we picked a very lispy part of
your book for him to read let's do it
would you would you mind start everyone
in the book has Irish accents also so
nobster dear a scratchy voice three
seniors were scrolling down at me the
leader of the group was Big Jim Gibbons
the sweatiest person I have ever
honestly I have no idea why his nickname
isn't sweaty Jimmy because he's not even
that big his sweatiness and his
nastiness are his most defining traits
stove cots are ain't for knob stirs yeah
Daffy knobs noobster I read the audible
version but that's because I didn't know
Andrew was available next time just
check the avails by the way they didn't
pay me much for it either so yeah Ronin
Boyle and the bridge of riddles is a new
book by Thomas Lennon funny for that you
said four high school kids and adults to
enjoy yeah I think like a patent it
gives a quote on the back of the book
which is Andrew will you read which is
you the book yeah on the bridge of
riddles is a touching funny read for
smart kids young and old flat-out
laughed out loud
Patton Oswalt you know and then weird
out yeah
am I completely unbiased opinion my good
friend Thomas Lennon as written perhaps
the most finest children's book of all
time in the ever burgeoning leprechaun
crime drama sub-mariner Alan and Douglas
Adams which you know ain't a bad thing
Weird Al your more books or to come
right this is the first of three well
yeah oh that's so exciting second one I
just finished this is a great birthday
gift a great what holiday is coming up
to Patrick's Day
the holidays coming up I mean like do
you get st. Patrick's Day gifts yes okay
okay well now you do I'm telling you
Thomas Lennon there's really no he's one
of the funniest people I've imagined and
like you are seriously one of your my
favorites i watch your stuff all the
time
I've been a fan for so long and I'm
really excited about your books and I'm
excited for kids - I need more funny
literature and for for young adults and
this is it Ronin Boyle and the bridge of
riddles get it order it on Amazon I'm
guessing it's if you get it at Barnes &
Noble there's a special edition that has
it comes with the trainings manual in
the back so I would get that one get
that one obviously get it wherever you
like but there and Nicky had only one
other question which is when is this
gonna be on great do we have to break do
we have more time okay we're gonna drag
those sheet metal men through the
garbage again
Warby Parker yeah my I used to know
people that would tell my family uses no
expensive glasses that you didn't want
my prescriptions that weren't that great
so as long as they're not against that
rape I'll be should be fine with worthy
partner I think I think frames and
styles that you like do you like TOMS
shoes I'm gonna fangirl out a little bit
and ask you about your character
lieutenant dangle from me talk about the
shorts and how those came to be the way
the shorts came to be is I was like this
guy should have shorts and then the
costume designer brought in like a
normal pair of khakis yeah and it's like
no no no I don't think you understand
[Music]
like weird that you can't look away yeah
so I ended up the only reason I found
out I just went smaller and smaller and
smaller the reason I found out how big
they actually are is because in the
movie the Reno 911
you see me making a pair like an
emergency I make a pair of the pants so
they're actually from the waistband to
the to the hem is 11 inches so it's a
really small short really small short
where those uncomfortable Oh hurt like
hell for years yeah I bet I mean is
horrible what would you wear underneath
that just a pair of briefs regular
briefs but sometimes well since we're
getting into it Nicky sometimes I
gave me smooth briefs so you wouldn't
get a little bunch of cranky lines and
such yeah you got stylus you know I know
it makes me feel good that you as a man
of experience you don't want line and
all the stuff that I mean wearing I was
um I got to portray Kurt Cobain on a
show that's coming out on Netflix where
I just dressed like a boy on TV and it
was the greatest time I've ever see that
thank you
yeah it's called historical rose it's
where comedians dresses dead celebrities
and roast each other in heaven yeah it's
good but I didn't know I was I thought I
was gonna play Princess Diana that's
what it was originally pitched to me so
I got to set being like I'm ready and
then they were like you're her Cobain
and it was I was scared because I've
never you roasting with got me into the
Friars Club in 1996 really oh yeah I've
been a friar since the 90s do you go
there a lot I was there on Friday what
do have soup but like I think like
thousands of dollars a year to get to go
there and have the soup nothing nothing
I do every time cuz I live in LA but I'm
a member of the Friars Club New York so
whenever I'm in town I feel this
obligation like I got to go to the
Friars Club but what you just show up or
do you tell them you're gonna you tell
them we're coming and make a big deal
and then you're like is there a show
that goes on there every it's just a
bunch of people sitting around older do
you like older people yeah do you like
soup yeah do you like try to think of
what else is there you got majors so
there's a lot of pictures of like Trump
on the wall and like Harvey Weinstein so
my joke from back in the day so my joke
is that we have more predators on the
wall at the Friars Club then at the
National Geographic yeah they all hang
out there too yeah it's a boys club
right used to be the red was the first
one to be like girls deserve to be in
here right and then they were like we
don't need to be here yeah like stupid
old man parts I feel
yeah gloria allred was the first person
i ran into her at another place that
reminds me of the Friars Club I rented
her at the Magic Castle
oh yeah old timey soupy place and I saw
her you know she was also in the Michael
Jackson documentary as I mean she's the
one oh yeah I don't want to spoil it but
he's weird no I was so I wanted to like
walk up to her me like thank you for all
you do for women and victims and I would
but she was having dinner with like her
nephew or something and I didn't want to
bother her but my friend was like you
have to and so he pulled of course I may
well be over certain was like she loves
you and she goes here's my card honey if
you ever need anything and then she was
like what do you do honey like kind of
getting another way and I was like I'm
the comedian she's like you know you can
go to the Friars Club now because of me
and I was like actually Thomas can you
get me in first really yeah yeah okay
yes just in if it's a Warby Parker
Thomas Lennon was our guest thank you so
much for being here again his book Ronan
Boyle in the bridge of riddles is
available everywhere now get it at
Barnes & Noble for a special edition of
the book order this for whatever team
you have in your life
who is interested in comedy who is
interested in magic leprechauns st.
Patrick's Day yeah I mean there's no one
funnier than Thomas Lennon and now he is
writing a young adult fiction and and
I'm excited for for kids to get a chance
to read this Ronin Boyle and the bridge
of riddles be the cool aunt or uncle in
your niece or nephews life and pick up
this book for them for whatever occasion
they have coming up oh that's right
that's right and by the way my last
question when is this come for weeks we
just moved it's getting free that's bad
that's really weird
yeah we did the man we got stacked
behind something else yeah
[Music]
I'm so jealous of her she wears glasses
sunglasses and all her interviews
because like as a woman that's a pet
said that's a dream strong it's a woman
all I want to do is like cancel out my
eyes Thomas Lennon thank you so much for
being here the best you're the best guys
when you're selling online getting your
orders out the door quickly can be tough
that's why you need shipstation comm
it's the fast and easy way to manage and
ship your orders all from one place ship
station helps you get orders out quickly
and keep customers happy Nikki I'm sorry
but my family's been the business of
shipping things from a bunch of
different places at a bunch of
inconvenient times your family needs to
look into a different business because
ship station is really what we do
Oh God do you order if that's the
disgusting habit you do like out in
public like what are you doing in
private
sometimes I'll fart in my hand and smell
my own hand it's about my own fart you
ever do that I honestly think that
you're being serious right I am being
serious why would I why why'd you do
that I don't know sometimes you just
want the smell of your own scent do you
um do you get a lot of feedback on the
show about me being mean to you
yeah do people think I bully you mm-hmm
so tell me a little bit about that
because you've never really let me know
I've had I've had you say it to people
in front of me like yeah some people say
that Nikki bullies me and that's the
first time I hear it no one you did that
I don't know what they could be talking
about I honestly don't know what they're
talking about we we because sometimes
you'll tell me like hey Nikki like so my
brother thinks that you will you bully
me sometimes and you make fun of me
uh-huh and I don't even understand what
they mean I think it could be your voice
what you just did you can do it again
what was that
oh no sassafras yeah that thing well
save the word sassafras and let's see if
I'm really that far off pretty sure
you're bullying me around back of frack
don't try to be funny
fine sassafras south of France say I had
some sassafras from a succotash I had
some sassafras and succotash in the
South of France do it I had some wait do
it again one more time let's go have
some sassafras and succotash in the
South of France let's go have some
sassafras and second - in the South of
France not bad what's the scariest thing
for you on a plane sitting next to you
[Laughter]
I'm all right
wait a second what do you hate more than
anything when you fly truly sitting next
to me bad turbulence no what is it
repair balloons it's try to say it right
turbulence turbulence that's right in my
teeth is that the problem turbulence
turbulence turbulence yeah we got there
what about if you were in a plane crash
and survived what would they send to
come get you to take you to the hospital
after the turbulence Oh any ambulance
yeah ambulance how do you say it
ambulance ambulance ambulance there you
go see meaning you
you try so hard with words it's like
what did you say today that was just so
not right
you said it yesterday and you tried to
like get through and you tried to oh
there was some word that's accessible oh
god oh god okay
wheeze again so what do you want your
comedy to be to people accessible what
accessible okay you said accessible so
you want people to be able to assess it
mean to like give notes on it no I
wonder you want people to it to be able
to reach more relatable okay so what's
the word accessible accessible
accessible accessible spell it ACCE as
as a ble that's right I think it's an AI
okay we're somewhere this cam is
bullying just making you say words no
yeah I think what could I do to make it
count as bullying because yeah I think
it is bullying I think today outside
people I think they don't they don't
like my mom doesn't appreciate it Oh
your mom does tell me tell me so your
mom listens and she's like no my mom
doesn't like the comments they leave on
my Instagram like which ones really got
her upset the most pride a one where you
called her fat whore I didn't know you
did idea all right our DM no the big
did not say that by the way so your mom
is not a fan of no no no my mom is a
huge fan of yours and she thinks that
you've helped me a shit-ton but then she
also doesn't understand why you're so
mean to me
but doesn't she understand that that's
part of life yes you're successful yeah
because I am mean to you
well I don't know if that's part I don't
know bullies say I think you just dad
slighted me I did yeah I think you enjoy
it
I do Cheers
[Music]
you